[Music]
okay everybody i am so thrilled today
because i am joined by grace byers aka
quinn and shaniqua sean day aka angie in
harlem all 10 episodes come out on prime
video this friday shaniqua give me the
love because i pronounced your last name
right i could see it in your face
seriously you said it right
[Laughter]
no that was like i i said it in my head
a couple times before i'm getting this
right i'm doing it
no problem um so i'm really excited to
talk to both of you i love the show
grace
one of my favorite things about this
show is relationship between quinn and
angie and it's so fun to watch how do
you guys go about finding that chemistry
with each other so well
well i i have to say this one was
it's unfair for for me to take any any
credit of any of this as soon as we did
the chemistry read we all gel together
so well that producers were asking it
like are you sure you guys didn't know
each other before this you sure and like
megan and i knew each other before this
and so we had a camaraderie but with
jerry and shaniqua like they just
slipped right in like it was no big
thing and we have just developed this
sisterhood that is so genuine and the
chemistry is so true
that i i just know and feel that's one
thing that will just not be debatable as
you guys watch the show it's just
how much we really do connect and
already trust each other and really um
are vulnerable with each other as we
create art together and create safe
spaces for one another
yeah 100 and it shows on screen like
that's what i love about this show is it
feels so real and i forget i'm watching
a show which is always good um shaniqua
you have probably the most comedic lines
in the show and you crush it do you feel
comedy comes easy to you or that like
where you're most comfortable
um that is an amazing question
honestly
yeah i used to do improv i kind of
started up doing improvisation it's how
i kind of i was able to escape out of
high school
i would join the improv club and i was
in the theater club and so um improv
gave me an opportunity to
speak because i spent a lot of my time
silencing myself i was like super
bullied at one point so i would just
like be the quiet kid in the classroom
um just to not bring attention to myself
and it wasn't until like i was able to
go on stage that i was allowed to
not say everything that i wanted to say
but like live freely and so because
improv was like my home away from home i
think comedy does come a little
naturally but then also too angie is
literally my grandma angelia is my
grandma and she's my cousin and she's my
auntie
so that woman i just i know her
you know oh
i love to hear that and that perfectly
leads to my next question which is for
grace grace the character of quinn did
you find a lot of yourself in it or
maybe a grandma grandpa what did you
find in quinn
i'm not gonna lie to you as i was
reading this the script and i was
looking at quinn i was thinking to
myself i don't really connect to quinn
like that you know what i mean like i
just feel like
like i'm i'm more hip to things i'm not
as naive like you know what i mean so i
i wasn't
i wasn't really feeling the quinn vibe
at first and as soon as i got to the
chemistry and i started reading it quinn
and i just aligned and as the show went
on i said i don't know what i was
thinking there is so much of me that's
in quinn so much of quinn that's in me
we're definitely not the same person
there's definitely decisions that we
would have made differently but it
helped me to understand more of where
she was coming from and really operate
from a place of truth and honesty and
like deep down i am obsessed with her i
love her so much like i just hug her
every time i'm i'm you know
speaking for her and and being a vessel
for her i just i hug her deep down
inside because i i feel like there's so
much more that is congruent with me and
quinn than i ever ever thought possible
yeah that's a great answer and it shows
how smart both of you are and how great
it appears on the screen with your
characters you really bring them to life
watch grace and shaniqua kill it all 10
episodes that's the whole season of
harlem is on prime video this friday so
you can fidget this weekend thank you so
much for joining me today guys i hope to
talk to you in the future
thank you so much to you